à première vue elle n'a rien de vraiment
différent des autres voitures juste une
autre compact peu banal mais dans les
faits la bio heidi ne ressemble en rien
à ses compétitrices
de l'intérieur on sent et entend tout de
suite la différence elle est extrêmement
puissant dit il on est littéralement
collé au siège mais la véritable
révolution se trouve sous le capot ce
home and as far antilles voici le moteur
essence dit-il il moteur électrique
le be why did i et la première hybride
entièrement conscient qu un phénomène
qui est en train de bousculer plusieurs
joueurs dans l'industrie automobile et
qui pourrait aider la chine à réduire
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
be why dit quinn a une autonomie de 70
km en mode électrique explique-t-il
alors que les autres hybrides ont
généralement 50 km d'autonomie
mais la grande différence est que les
batteries nos compétiteurs sont garantis
pour cinq ans alors que les nôtres le
son avis et il y à toutes les autres
caractéristiques
vous pouvez la stationner à distance
vous pouvez l'utiliser comme génératrice
il y a même une télévision satellite
intégrer autant de nouveautés qui font
courir les consommateurs comme toujours
l'ingénieur se cherche une deuxième
voiture tout ce qu'ils entendent
labillois il enchante le ratio prix
performance et excellence pour aller au
travail je parcours 40 km par jour ce
qui veut dire que le mode électrique
mais le week-end si je veux aller plus
loin et bien je peux utiliser le moteur
est sur eux selon ce spécialiste
automobile
les chinois ont compris qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas compétitionner avec les
constructeurs traditionnels
c'est pourquoi les fabricants
investissent massivement dans
l'industrie électrique
leur but est simple devenir les leaders
mondiaux nous avons commencé à produire
des véhicules verts presque en même
temps que les pays étrangers dit et
malgré un peu de retard nous avons
réussi à produire notre propre
technologie
certaines aux constructeurs offrent
d'ailleurs plusieurs nouveautés mises en
marché en 2013 les billets dit quinn la
plus populaire des votes jaune verte
chinoise est déjà la quatrième voiture
électrique la plus vendue dans le monde
et est en voie de devenir la plus vendue
d'ici la fin de l'année
un succès qui s'explique en partie par
les généreuses subventions
gouvernementales dans le but de
s'attaquer à l'intense nuage de fumée
qui recouvrent le pays
pékin rembourse 6000 $ à chaque acheteur
de voiture hybride à shanghai la ville
ont fait autant faisant passer le prix
de la bio a dit de 45 à 32 mille dollars
canadiens
des incitatifs de taille rendu
nécessaire puisque 24 millions de
voitures font leur apparition chaque
année sur les routes du pays un problème
gigantesque pour le régime communiste
la chine est devenue le plus important
marché automobile de la planète et les
dizaines de millions de pots
d'échappement qui crache chaque jour du
monoxyde de carbone produisent le tiers
de la pollution dans le pays dit le
gouvernement
les primordial de réduire les émissions
faites par les véhicules à essence et de
ramener au ciel bleu dans le pays dit il
les gens sont surpris de voir le ciel
bleu maintenant ce n'est pas de bon sens
l'environnement nous préoccupe tous
ajoute john
alors si je peux faire ma part avec
cette voiture tant mieux
en fait bill wiggin fournit plus à la
demande le constructeur a vu ses ventes
passer de 2000 hybride par mois en demi
à plus de 5000 en juillet la tente pour
les acheteurs comme tout est maintenant
de plusieurs semaines j'achète
aujourd'hui si je ne commande pas tout
de suite le temps sera encore plus
longue
en achetant tout de suite je vais
attendre trois ou quatre mois avant
d'avoir made by heidi grâce à la
popularité de la vie wahedi et s'est
vendu cet été plus de voitures
électriques en chine qu'aux états unis
une première porteuse pour
l'environnement même si pour l'instant
le marché demeure marginal moins d'un
pour cent de toutes les voitures
achetées en chine font électrique ici
mon côté radio canada sunrise